[Music]
[Applause]
damn that feels good
oh it's been a while oh first of all i
got to be completely honest with you
guys
very important i don't know what memes
are about what are the kids laughing at
these days
i'm off my game it's been so long i've
done a meme review
this is not no longer meme review okay
this is different this will be
me trying to figure out what the kids
like all right i'm i'm old now
i may have shaved my beard it will come
back and the beard will come back
tomorrow don't worry but
for now let's get into the memes
first meme i know this one at least
among us
that's right the game blew up big time
let's check out some among his memes
that's kind of cute not gonna lie i just
love how big this
game got because everyone's on board
it's cool i like it
everyone's killing each other and lying
and screaming to each other
it's wholesome why did you kill our
claim
what are you talking about bro i was
doing task in medical yeah
i don't know sasuke kind of assessed to
be honest we already got cosplay all
right i
oh that's such a good halloween costume
the dumb one
legit tempted dude i might go for that
that's funny
we plan to cut all homeless people in
half by 2025
good job uk homeless people be like
bruh sound effect but bass boosted with
echo
and reverb side
i saw him i saw him do it sonic was not
an
imposter guess he was just a regular
imposter after all
this me all right some of these suck
dude okay yeah
i get it i get it it takes you a second
to look and then you're like oh
i get it there's an imposter among us
all right how long is it gonna take me
[ __ ] i actually don't know is it madoka
girl reference
no what is it then then then i don't
know
then i don't know spacesuit check helmet
check inflatable flamingo i'm ready for
work
i'm ready the wires baby smash 64
character artwork
smash broad character artwork yeah i get
it i'm i'm down with the kids i get it
has this been done yet i guess not
all right i like that one that's cool
why are you running
oh your crewmate name every task right
now
do it oh he started that's kind of sad
i i would love if someone did some math
on
among us right and or statistics and see
just the the general gameplay of the
imposters versus crewmates like what are
crewmates more likely to say
what are imposters more likely to say or
use his alibi right there has to be a
correlation
or difference or how much they speak and
those kind of
yeah i'm curious someone really nerdy do
that do some stats analyze a bunch of
youtuber gameplays
and and yeah that'd be sick crewmate
there's one imposter among us
i don't see it i'm legit do not know
that oh is it ditto
it's that i got it i got it i got it
grab it there's one imposter among us
where's monica
that [ __ ] we need a sequel of that game
now
there's one imposter adobe photoshop
it's not updated
imposter when a body is reported where
where
yeah here it is this is it this is
literally it crewmates when a body's
reported
yellow self report greece this is
exactly what i was talking about i
wonder if like
there's more stuff that you can
statistically prove that that's the case
me watching the person who killed me and
among us say it wasn't
yeah how could he lie like that that's
terrible
when someone calls an emergency meeting
10 seconds into the game and gets voted
off
i love democracy you deserved it red
always says
this was the hardest game of my life
blue pink orange brown oh god
it's purple wait what
gunshot dead body why would purple do
this
how could purple do this crewmate there
is one imposter among us
oh that's cute will you please listen
i'm not the imposter
he's the butter he was not the imposter
yeah that's the name of the game cry
about it more cry babies
there is an impasta among us all right
the memes are dead you did it
you killed it when there's three
imposters left me imposter
my detectives remember this
meeting just wanted to say hi yes
people you don't know true fear me medic
yeah
electrical i mean today's code hey
they said it couldn't be done you took
everything from me i don't know he kind
of says
i don't know about every game anymore
impostor of the event what is your
wisdom imposter should be allowed to
read ghost chat
oh that'd be funny i would love that
yeah that's a good idea among us
me running for the emergency money when
someone banned
that's a good memes when you're trying
to convince everyone
you aren't the imposter but just make
yourself look more sus
yeah that's what's so good about the
game let's check out reddit
i don't even give a [ __ ] i saw air go
into vents
that's how events work damn
damn damn
don't go in electrical alone boys are
sick
i called this meeting today just to say
that i had the smoothest card swipe of
my life
that's impossible oh
oh rick asks oh my god hear me
i'm not afraid anymore
[Applause]
[Laughter]
septifier well done septiplier hey
hey i need peter here
to kill both of them
[Laughter]
imposter see i love this it's got a
whole community around it so cool
i'm not even reviewing memes at this
point where are we dropping boys 2018
2019 what are we building boys 2019
who we voting boys
among us with randoms is something else
it's orange
i saw him orange is dead oh my god where
you reported the bloody i don't know
blue kind of sucks i don't know about
that one man
there's so many good memes
and yellow bastards
this better not be a spoiler i just
started watching come on
[Laughter]
[Music]
dead mean
oh yeah of course why has no one done
this correlation he's not the imposter
[Music]
nice nice that's great
your honor my client cannot be the
imposter
he was in electrical the entire time hey
that's
cat i was in electrical
um i'm sorry good [ __ ] yeah amongst me
i i'm giving it a 10 just because it's
been so much fun uh
it's been a while since a game came out
that really just changed so much
i mean it happens but i'm on board i
love it
super dope it was fun with fall guys but
among us is like
man what a year what a year i'm so happy
all right
next me
all right let's figure out let's figure
this out together okay we got this
so i've seen these guys right i've been
thinking about this for a month now this
has been going
viral who painted the mona lisa mona
lisa
yeah who painted the mona lisa
mona lisa yeah
why do they look they look they look
fake what is that called the
thing face swap thing what is it you
know what i mean right it looks fake it
looks oh god it looks so comfortable who
painted the mona lisa davinki everyone
knows it's the binky
why does loki look like me a little bit
i don't
i don't like this dabbing i don't know
about you guys but i think
that i think i don't know for sure
i can say it's kind of such but i think
they might be trolling
and pretending to be funny haha davinki
you get zero done next one
i give you fire you give me rock
good deal that was it that was the mean
hey catch me later i'll buy you a beer
i give you fire you give me rock
good deal what the hell this means sucks
dude
i give you fire you give me rock
hmm good deal oh
i'm done zero another zero i i i'm only
here for longest means at this point
that's
stupid dude
these have been blowing out it's not
funny and we've seen this a million
times too
what book opinion will get you in this
situation and pretty much any
book opinion drop a theme park opinion
that'll make you feel like this
who cares is this just me drop a food
take
that gets this type of reaction anyone
that calls spaghetti noodles
needs to get the knife the actual knife
all right i'll threaten you
it's not noodles you dumb schmuck i have
to say that because i have an italian
wife she'll kill me otherwise
drop a movie take that will get this
type of react i don't what is this
unpopular opinion but i would rather
wake up to 20 actual swords point at me
than to have this picture six thousand
times a day accompanied by sense like
pizza not good cellular games are boring
actually
yeah so the games are not even that good
i got a hot take online i'm so freaking
cool right
look like just like this guy i don't
give a [ __ ] right huh look at this
this image he doesn't care and neither
do i when i say stuff on the internet
yeah totally believe me guys
i give hot text left and right i don't
care i don't care i'm just a cool guy
i'm just like whatever i have my own
opinion deal with it haters
that's just my thing this is what i do i
can't help myself i gotta tell my hot
takes online even though i know people
are gonna get pissed off
can't help it guys hot take guys hey i
said hot take before i did a hot take
and i posted to me huh
we got a problem now what we need a
special jail like a special prison for
people with hot takes
do you understand what i mean and then
they can all just go and get hot text to
each other all day
and no one has to listen to it look no
one cares about your opinion
it doesn't matter just because you're
the only one saying it
doesn't make you special you bring no
value to this earth
nothing just because you act ballsy over
a goddamn meme
don't mean nothing why do i get so
pissed about this is this annoying
the internet was a mistake you
understand that we're not supposed to
hear everyone's opinion all the time for
a reason
before the internet no hot takes all
right
you pick you pay you wanna yeah
yeah next week
cursed emoji it's this one this for me
is for me senor random country find oil
usa
for me oh okay
lightsabers exist general grievous be
like is for
me is for me senor earth
exists genghis khan is for me
get it then he [ __ ] a bunch of women and
spread his dna across the world
woman uterus exists genghis khan
sorry okay chinese finger trap
hell
that was actually good random russian
about to vote putin is for
you want to vote for me can i do that
face by the way
it's for me a like on this video it's
for me
i really become unfunny and i really
truly feel it
don't worry i am aware a girl in ancient
greece exists
zeus is for me it's funny because it's
true
get it get the joke get the joke you
haven't read the original
mythology of ancient greeks french
man [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] say what you
want father in porn gets a new wife
his son he's for me wait what father
gets a new one
oh redditor makes a good meme youtuber's
word robotic voice it for me
now i i do it without doing robotic
voice you can thank me later
by smashing like subscribe is that it is
that all the memes i've been missing out
on
everyone be like meme ruby when well
there you go i'm
only here for the humongous memes really
thank you guys for watching hope you had
fun
i had fun and that's all i care about
leave us
actually you know what i do brothers now
breakfast yeah have a great one see you
[Music]
tomorrow